تغيرات في المناخ وزحف صحراوي خطراني
يمثلان تحديدا وجوديا لسكان الولايه
الشماليه هنا في السودان هذه الارض تعتبر
من اخصب الاراضي الزراعيه غير ان الرمال
التي يعلتها صعبه من مهمه استصلاحها
[موسيقى]
بدا الحديث جهرا في الولايه الشماليه عن
اتساع دائره الخطا الذي اصبح مهددا للارض
والانسان والحيوان امطار تهطلوا على ارض
ما تعودت عليها ورمال تتحرك بسرعه معلنه
ان لا مكان في مستقرها للزرع والانسان
الافراد اللي بيزرعوا مزارع بتدفن يعني
التغيرات المناخيه المطر المطر مؤثر جدا
لما نيجي عايزين في الشمال
اما الامطار التي شهدتها المنطقه مؤخرا
يحدثك عنها المتضررون من المزارعين الذين
قد تضرهم الامطار الى تغيير نمط الزراعي
اذا استمرت التغيرات المناخيه
مع الامطار مع البريد الكثير حتى السنه دي
يعني البرد الشديد ده اخر النخيل ده
المجهودات الرسميه تتوالى بزراعه الاحزمه
الزراعيه وزياده المساحات الخضراء ورفع
الوعي بمخاطر التغيرات المناخيه
من الولايات المتحده الصحراوي والزحف
الصحراوي طبعا بيعدي كارثه في المنطقه
الغابات هي بتتمثل في اقامه واقيه في
المنطقه التي تتعرض للشعب لتغليل عمليه
سرعه الرياح بالتالي تثبيت الكزبره
الرمليه
والعلم يتجه صوب قمه المناخ في مدينه شرم
الشيخ المصريه ليضع الجار السوداني نفسه
من الدول التي شهدت تغيرا في مناخه تمظهر
في ارتفاع درجات الحراره وزياده معدلاته
طول الامطار خاصه في مناطق الانتاج ما قد
يتسبب في تاثيرات على الامن الغذائي وهجره
ونزوحي ملايين الناس محمد عثمان العربيه